bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous la
coalition à venir Québec de François
LEGO a remporté une victoire
convaincante vous le voyez avec les
chiffres derrière moi 90 candidats élus
le Parti libéral va former l'opposition
officielle avec une vingtaine d'élus
également même si on a perdu un certain
nombre de députés Québec solidaire
résiste à la vague kakis contre 11
candidats le Parti québécois en aura
trois candidats dont le chef Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon ça serait de
l'État hier soir et finalement
eric duem n'a pas réussi à percer cette
armure caquiste même s'il avait quand
même un bon pourcentage de voix qui est
exprimé vous le voyez ici avec
13%. ça ça va faire l'objet beaucoup
beaucoup de discussions et d'analyses et
de débats au cours des prochaines
semaines peut-être des prochains mois on
verra bien toute participation juste
avant de parler à nos collègues sur le
terrain il est entre 65 et 66 % à peu
près d'une tendance à la baisse qui se
maintient bon on vous a dit qu'on allait
sur le terrain nos cinq caravaniers ceux
qui ont passé 36 jours avec différents
chefs sont tous là je compte en voir
qu'ils ont encore un certain sourire ce
matin après avoir passé autant de temps
dans un autobus et dans des chambres
d'hôtel je vous dis tout de suite lire
pas à la maison s'en vient chers
collègues je commence tout de suite avec
vous bien évidemment venir pour savoir
bon monsieur le Gaulle on l'a entendu
hier il a même dit qu'il avait quand
même souri un peu lui aussi durant cette
campagne électorale ce que je retiens
c'est que certains s'attendaient à ce
qu'il fallait qu'ils disent qu'il est le
premier ministre de tous les Québécois
parce que c'est sûr qu'on lendemain
d'une campagne électorale avec cinq
parties politiques il y a des divisions
puis on le voit dans les résultats du
vote on voit que les quatre autres
parties sont pas mal à égalité au niveau
du pourcentage d'appui donc François
Legault prend acte qui a des Québécois
qui ont voté pour eux et qui voulaient
les voir performer davantage mais en
même temps on voit qu'il est très fier
de son résultat il avait le sourire
fendu jusqu'aux oreilles notamment parce
qu'il affirme que son gouvernement fait
élire le plus grand nombre de femmes
dans l'histoire en fait tout parti
confondu on s'aperçoit que c'est à peu
près de soixantaine de femmes qui vont
faire leur entrée à l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui est quand même pas mal
il faut le reconnaître donc atterri
champagne Jourdain qui est la nouvelle
députée de Duplessis ça c'est sur la
côte nord et Madame champagne-jourdain
sera la première femme autochtone a
foulé le sol du salon bleu François
Legault hier dans son discours
clairement à se rappeler finalement les
impacts qu'on peut avoir
le message qu'on a eu le message qu'on a
eu aujourd'hui ce soir c'est continuons
mais
une élection ça divise
pourtant je pense que bien plus de
choses au Québec qui nous rassemble
quelque chose qui nous divise les
Québécois forment un grand peuple quand
je clique Québécois forment un grand
peuple
je parle de tous les Québécois
de toutes les régions de tous les âmes
de toutes les origines je vais être le
premier ministre de tous les Québécois
[Applaudissements]
et François Legault va répondre à nos
questions il y a un point de presse qui
est prévu à 14h30 cet après-midi parfait
merci à plus tard Alexandre maintenant
on est parti libérale reste l'opposition
mais quand même il faut constater que
ces appuis ont fondu
Dominique Anglade de pas voulu laisser
paraître d'émotions négatives hier mais
quand on regarde les chiffres les
chiffres parlent parce que pour le
moment on parle d'une vingtaine lors de
sièges 21 sièges pour le Parti libéral
c'est 6 de moins qu'au moment du
déclenchement des élections mais c'est
surtout au chapitre des votes que la
chute pour le Parti libéral et les
vertigineuse 14% des votes pour le Parti
libéral hier c'est moins que Québec
solidaire c'est moins que le Parti
québécois alors il y aura pour le Parti
libéral un travail de reconstruction
indéniable il faudra rebâtir cette base
militante qu'on a moins vu pendant les
élections madame Anglade en est tout à
fait consciente elle dit qu'elle est
prête à relever ce défi de la
reconstruction on peut l'écouter comme
je vous dis hier elle était tout sourire
malgré les résultats qui n'étaient pas
si en balançait pour son parti
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochains mois dans les prochaines
années vous allez voir que je vais
déployer la même énergie la même
conviction la même ambition que je
caresse pour nous tous ici au Québec et
vous allez voir que ensemble on est
capable d'accomplir de grandes choses
pour un Québec qui représente l'ensemble
des Québécois
presque je vous dirais que les votes
sont vraiment concentrés à Montréal pour
pour le parti libérale les sièges aussi
un petit enjeu dans Verdun là la partie
libéral qui ne concerne pas la victoire
à Québec solidaire on verra s'il y aura
un recontage et je termine en vous
disant que Dominique englade fera face
aux auteur à un vote de confiance de ces
militants parce que c'est ce que prévoit
la constitution du Parti libéral quand
un chef ne gagne pas les élections merci
Alexandre
maintenant vers Valérie Québec solidaire
visait le statut de position officielle
et bien des gens qui avaient raison de
le croire d'ailleurs mais finalement ça
se matérialise pas
il y avait beaucoup de déception hier
soir au rassemblement de Québec
solidaire parce qu'on espérait faire
plusieurs gains et surtout faire des
gains à l'extérieur de Montréal et ça ne
s'est pas avéré on se retrouve donc ce
matin chez les soldataires avec 11
députés en tout c'est un de plus parce
qu'on est parvenu à ravir deux châteaux
forts libéraux moi je contrairement à
Alexandre j'ai peut-être
vous donner la version solidaire de de
du résultat d'enverdun puisque donc
presque 500 voix donc d'avance pour la
Solidaire alléliana Zaga Mendes dans
cette circonscription là ça c'est
vraiment une victoire qui est arrivée
très tard dans la nuit autre gain duquel
on se félicite chez Québec solidaire
c'est dans Maurice Richard à rudevoisier
donc qui devient député ce gars qui fera
son entrée à l'Assemblée nationale en
revanche j'ai vraiment une défaite qui a
fait mal et c'est dans ouais de Noranda
Témiscaming emilyse laissa-terrier donc
qui a perdu ce comté au profit de la CAQ
hier Gabriel nado Dubois a été claire il
sera une opposition vigilante à
l'Assemblée nationale il va se poser à
toute mauvaise décision que la carte
prendra en environnement notamment
est-ce que je laisse entendre le coup
pour te Carole solidaire
qu'on le veuille ou non on est face à
une vague cactus mais dans ce contexte
là si la tendance se maintient Québec
solidaire sera le seul parti
d'opposition à résister à cette vague
cachée je veux être clair je veux être
clair avec François Legault à chaque
fois qu'il va faire un pas en avant pour
l'environnement je serai son partenaire
à chaque fois qu'il va vouloir faire un
pas en arrière je serai son adversaire
ah voilà on s'est en quelque sorte
réjoui hier soir en disant que Québec
solidaire était le seul parti qui
n'avait pas perdu de plumes après le à
la lumière des résultats d'hier très
bien merci beaucoup Valérie
le chef conservateur
Eric Dumas raté son entrée à l'Assemblée
nationale Jean-Claude à l'impression
qu'il avait commencé à mettre les freins
un peu au cours des derniers jours sur
sur les attentes peut-être de ces
partisans
oui oui définitivement tempéré les
attentes en disant peu importe le
résultat même si on ne fait et les roues
qu'un député on est gagnant parce que on
se comparait à 2018 où on avait récolté
un petit peu plus d'un pour cent du vote
il a d'ailleurs dans son discours Eric
diamiaire parler de Québec solidaire en
2007 qui avait remporté seulement 4% du
vote donc il a voulu vraiment
consoler ces militants il a parlé de
distorsion électorale c'est comme ça
qu'il appelle donc les problèmes avec le
mode de scrutin selon lui étant donné
que le Parti conservateur a quand même
récolté 13% du vote populaire aucun
député alors que les libéraux 14% et une
vingtaine de députés
Eric diom est parfaitement conscient
aussi qui l'a surfé sur la vague de
l'opposition mesure sanitaire hier il a
voulu dire qu'il serait encore là en
2026 il y a eu beaucoup de deuxième
position le Parti conservateur a quand
même réussi à s'imposer dans certaines
circonscriptions comme l'alternative
peut-être pour les prochaines élections
mais n'en demeure préoccupations pour
irrégione à savoir là la prochaine
bataille du Parti conservateur quel sera
telle on peut écouter donc une partie de
son discours d'hier soir
vous avez été la plus belle expérience
de humaine de ma vie j'en serai jamais
trop reconnaissant on est parfait qu'une
claque une bottine qu'on a fait ce que
personne ne fait dans l'histoire
politique récente au Québec c'est grâce
à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
puissent besoin de vous autres encore
plus au cours des quatre prochaines
années pour consolider puis agrandir ce
mouvement-là ok je serai encore là la
prochaine campagne électorale ça c'est
clair net et précis OK
un mot interminant Marc-André sur Bose
Nord les le Parti conservateur avait ses
yeux sur cette circonscription là et ça
a été très serré jusqu'à la fin il y a
seulement 200 voix qui séparent Olivier
Dumet le candidat conservateur du
candidat kakiste Luc provincial qui a
été élu donc on peut s'attendre à ce
qu'il y a une demande de recomptage
attend donc des détails du parti en ce
sens merci beaucoup Jacques Audrey à
plus tard
bon et Sébastien il fallait attendre
longtemps avant de savoir que Paul
saint-pierre-pla mon nom finalement été
élu dans son comté Camille lorrain mais
il reste que le parti a connu la pire
performance de son histoire
les mines étaient plutôt basses ici
Marc-André je vous dirais au
rassemblement du Parti québécois qui est
effectivement connaît la pire des fêtes
électorales de son histoire l'un des
rares moments d'extination ça a été la
victoire de Paul saint-pierre-famandre
dans sa circonscription là les militants
ont explosé de joie le chef du PQ
remporte son pari il a des faits son
adversaire de la CAQ le député sortant
de Camille Loret une circonscription
baptisée en l'honneur du père de la loi
101 donc c'est hautement symbolique pour
pas saint-pierre-florandon qui fera son
entrée à l'Assemblée nationale dans son
discours il a admis que les résultats ne
sont pas au rendez-vous en termes de
siège le PQ remporte trois
circonscriptions avec des victoires
également dans Matane matapedia et les
îles de la Madeleine alors qu'il avait
obtenu 10 sièges à la dernière élection
mais Paul saint-pierre-florandon a fait
remarquer que le PQ au vote populaire a
fait mieux que le Parti libéral du
Québec qui forme pourtant l'opposition
officielle alors il s'en est pris lui
aussi au mode de scrutin on écoute le
chef du Parti québécois
est-ce normal qu'un parti politique qui
obtient environ 40% des voix remporte
70% des sièges une fois cette élection
terminée absolument rien n'empêche de
réussir une réforme du mode de scrutin
rien n'empêche la CAQ de revenir à son
engagement initial et de collaborer avec
tous les autres parties de position pour
qu'ensemble nous réussissions ce défi de
la démocratie
mais encore une fois des châteaux forts
piquent se sont effondrés hier du
Plessis sur la côte nord Joliette
Jonquière Rimouski Gaspé Bonaventure ont
échappé aux parties québécois donc la
victoire de Monsieur Saint-Pierre
Plamondon laisse un coup moins amer en
bouche mais difficile de regarder ses
résultats et d'y voir une victoire merci
beaucoup à vous aussi Sébastien au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI